[Música]
[Aplausos]
a vontade pessoal
a primeira palestra é por um monstro do
mundo um pouco de sono ver se eu consigo
perder um pouco você é muito satisfeito
pelo convite da arapuã e e ambiente que
o que eu me sinto muito à vontade porque
na verdade o nosso trabalho é muito feio
dentro das universidades
bom eu resolvi contar um pouco da minha
história e fez o corte em 1984 em 1984
como vocês podem observar o mundo era
bastante diferente era um mundo um mundo
diferente do que a gente conhece o que a
gente conhece hoje e 84 foi o ano em que
entrei na faculdade eu passei no
vestibular de economia da ufrgs e
pretendia estudar para depois pensar o
que eu faria do ponto de vista
profissional
só que naquele ano acontece a primeira
greve das universidades federais
e eu fiquei completamente ocioso eo meu
pai acabou me convocando para que eu
fosse trabalhar com ele porque afinal um
adolescente de 17 anos em casa não é
algo que muito muito saudável bom
naquele tempo
o meu pai tinha começado como livreiro
ele começou nos anos 60 e nem 84 ele já
tinha uma empresa que eu achava que era
uma grande entre essa localizada em
porto alegre na verdade com vocês podem
ver nós tínhamos duas garagens e essas
duas garagens formavam uma loja que era
a sede da nossa então editora artes
médicas o limitado e quando então
comecei a trabalhar e que meus amigos me
e no fim hoje depois comecei a trabalhar
naquela agência
hoje a gente tem 2.400 títulos
publicados vários selos editoriais de
ter liderança e várias áreas do
conhecimento
quando eu comecei a a trabalhar naquela
época meus amigos me perguntavam mas
céus o kikito que no brasil com o
negócio editorial não tem uma opção
melhor afinal um país que se lê pouco
e no caso e no teu caso ainda é aqui que
trabalha com livros acadêmicos e
profissionais talvez ainda seja pior
nas faculdades os professores indicavam
os livros e os alunos ao invés de
comprar os livros e trocava os livros
mas a questão é que o meu pai de uma
paixão muito grande por esse negócio e
essa paixão acabou me contaminando ea
decisão não foi muito racional a decisão
foi muito mais por paixão do que por
qualquer decisão um pouco mais
estratégica
além disso a gente é uma outra
dificuldade não é uma questão óbvia uma
editora principalmente de livros
acadêmicos e profissionais está
localizada no rio grande do sul
nós somos a única editora considerada
grande porte que está fora do eixo o são
paulo então longe do mercado então ainda
tinha mais esse fator pode dificultar é
o projeto é decisão
no fim e isso que para nós era pra ser o
problema acabou se transformando em uma
vantagem competitiva como a indústria
editorial uma indústria que é muito
orientada produto ou seja o gestor
tradicional acredita que tendo um bom
livro e um bom autor não precisa mais
fazer nenhum esforço que o mercado se
encarrega do resto como nós estávamos
longe dos grandes mercados nós temos que
investir numa rede de filiais e talvez
isso tenha feito a diferença frente aos
nossos aos nossos concorrentes
bom aqui eu pulo pouco avança um pouco
da história e e aqui eu vou pro ano de
2009 em 2008 com vocês vão se recordar o
mundo estava prestes a acabar e e houve
a crise à crise até pegou muito mais
forte nos estados unidos que aqui no
brasil
e então há o que aconteceu a magro o rio
que é uma das principais editoras
acadêmicas e profissionais profissionais
do mundo resolveu fechar suas operações
internacionais inclusive aqui do brasil
e por uma felicidade muito grande nossa
nós que já eram os parceiros porque
traduzíamos vários livros da mágoa o rio
fomos escolhidos para sermos os a
empresa que ficaria com os ativos deles
aqui no brasil por um processo
competitivo então isso pra mim foi um
momento muito especial porque meu pai
tinha começado nos anos 60
vendendo livros no porta mala do carro
livros muitos livros amazon rio livros
em inglês naquela nos anos 60 que não
haviam livros disponíveis em língua
portuguesa
poxa é agora depois de um intervalo de
30 ou 40 anos nós estávamos tendo a
oportunidade de sermos os donos da área
magrão hill em então pra mim é que ele
foi a coroação de uma de uma trajetória
foi algo muito muito muito especial
a questão é a seguinte é então fez o
assunto desculpe isso foi em 2000 e 2009
em 2009 eu estou muito satisfeito que se
por um lado tinha ido muito além do que
imaginava que poderia chegar numa
pequena história do rio grande do sul
mas por outro lado o mundo era
completamente diferente se antes quando
eu entrei no negócio nós tínhamos o
problema da pirataria física agora a
gente se dava o problema agora é a
pirataria digital o mundo tinha outras
fontes de conhecimento que não mas que
não mais os livros e outras fontes de
comercialização então assim a indústria
é completamente diferente então no dia
seguinte que nós fechamos como o rio já
começamos a nos perguntar por chamada
tudo bem nós chegamos agora que vamos
ter que nos reinventar
então nós começamos a pensar talvez no
futuro não existam mais livros como nós
conhecemos
além disso talvez no futuro não existam
mais as aulas como nós conhecemos então
isso é importante aqui na faculdade é
uma provocação e talvez no futuro não
está nem mais na gravação como nós
conhecemos hoje se fala muito né dos
profissionais buscaram competências
específicas e não mais uma graduação já
que o mundo é tão líquido e imutável
então nós pensávamos que inventar o que
nós nos damos conta é que o conhecimento
é algo que que sempre é algo que que é
permanente é importante e que a nossa
vocação era transmissão do conhecimento
em questão talvez nós pudéssemos ampliar
nossos horizontes e não mais se
pensarmos na empresa como empresa
historial mas sim como empresa de
educação e foi então que nós começamos a
fazer
um vídeo rápidos só pra um dia o céu foi
o limite
e até plana
as ondas eram imbatíveis
e as profundezas um mistério
um dia o tempo foi calculado em grãos de
areia e já dependeu dos raios do sol
o conhecimento já foi marcado nas
paredes de uma caveira já foi detido em
páginas guardado em paz
jacob uma folha de papel ou disquete um
cd
no fim o importante é a evolução que o
conhecimento traz pode ser só voz
pode ser um livro pode ser uma tela pode
ser um difuso por onde o conhecimento
precisar fundo
nós estaremos lá
[Música]
o grupo a ajudando a encontrar respostas
para os desafios da educação
bom então nós resolvemos resolvemos
então tenta ampliar o nosso o nosso foco
de atuação e nos reinventarmos mais uma
vez uma definimos que o negócio em geral
pra nós é tão importante que é algo que
que esse realmente nosso dna já numa uma
segunda geração permaneceria mais como
um pilar ser o pilar de conteúdo da
empresa
então eu tivemos a primeira iniciativa
que não era uma iniciativa meramente
editorial
mas claro que é que aproveitando a
experiência que tínhamos aos
relacionamentos que tínhamos
principalmente na área da saúde onde 50%
dos nossos livros são dedicado à área de
biociências
começamos um projeto de educação
continuada é então procuramos as
sociedades médicas brasileiras e
começamos algo que era um modelo de
negócio diferente do negócio tradicional
historial era um modelo de assinatura
com receita recorrente e que pela
primeira vez nós usamos a tecnologia
como um componente da nossa solução e
pela primeira vez também nós tínhamos a
oportunidade de interagir e
interatividade com o público porque no
papel de editor não se consegue tentar
de interatividade com o leitor porque é
a venda dos livros é feita através de
tudo uma livraria de uma distribuidora
já não consegue interagir então com isso
também ele também teria oportunidade de
melhoria contínua
fomos bastante bem sucedidos nessa nessa
iniciativa e isso nos deu coragem então
a confiança necessária para continuar
empreendendo de aconteceu algo que não
estava previsto em função da parceria
que eu contei pra vocês como o rio que
se estabeleceu em 2009
nós passamos como então a parceiros
oficiais a magra rio começamos a ser
convidados para participar das
convenções de vendas da empresa nos
estados unidos na primeira convenção que
nós participamos o grande mostra essa
primeira convenção era uma parceria que
estava
procurando entre humor o rio e
blackwater a blackwater da empresa que
inventou a os ambientes virtuais de
aprendizagem ou seja a plataforma
infraestrutura que possibilita a
educação à distância então estava se
estabelecendo essa parceria eu fiquei
muito motivado porque enxerguei que
seria um caminho que movimentaria nossa
migração do negócio editorial para o
mundo da educação e nos possibilitaria
também tem uma agenda diferente com as
universidades até então tínhamos muito
diálogo com os corpos corpo docência
sessões de ensino para que essa
divulgação adoção dos nossos livros mas
não tinha uma pauta com os com os
gestores
aí então a fizemos a parceria como o rio
e daí criamos daí se criou um novo
problema porque éramos neófitos em
tecnologia
a única experiência que tínhamos até
então que a tecnologia era sermos
usuários de uma plataforma é de
aprendizagem na nossa iniciativa de
educação a distância como é que operaria
mas esse negócio fomos talvez até um
pouco responsáveis onde fizemos uma
aquisição de uma de uma de uma startup
que foi incubada na universidade federal
de santa maria era uma empresa que é
especializada em educação corporativa o
que nós adquirimos na verdade foi o
talento de cinco jovens que tinham
paixão pela educação à distância e
tinham como o sonho trabalhar com
blackboard então esses essa equipe cinco
caras fizeram a operação blackboard se
estabelecer no brasil no começo com mais
heroísmo e transpiração do que
inspiração hoje a blackwater é uma
plataforma que atende 1 milhão e meio de
alunos no brasil está em várias seções
importantes como o ibmec insper sp ms
senac entre outros
bom daí surgiu daí surge um outro
desafio uma outra oportunidade nós
instalavam os all blacks ou nas
instituições de ensino as instituições a
passavam em uma plataforma interessante
tinham infraestrutura mas tinha um pouco
conteúdo para o povo ao popular essas
essas plataformas
nós criamos uma uma plataforma de
conteúdo que se utiliza
do material dos nossos livros mas ela
está embarcada numa no modelo uma
metodologia aprendizagem que é muito
contemporânea
nós acreditamos que os livros textos
foram concebidos por uma educação quer
uma educação justin case que a educação
que eu tive uma educação onde se
aprendia muito de coisas que
provavelmente nós usaríamos na prática
equipara a geração atual tem que a
educação tem que ser uma educação just
in time
ou seja como o conteúdo está a um clique
de distância o que nós precisamos
enxergar neste ano os nossos jovens é
que eles tenham um raciocínio crítico
tenham a senso crítico e que saibam
raciocinar quando submetidos há
problemas
então no fim usamos o velho conteúdos
dos livros textos mas numa roupagem com
uma metodologia nova que para o que
pressupõe a aaa os princípios da
aprendizagem ativa
bom então há de novo é esse caminho que
nós essa jornada que nós seríamos ela
não foi planejado as coisas foram foram
acontecendo e há dois anos atrás
acabamos usando conta que tínhamos uns
transformado talvez na principal empresa
de soluções para a educação do mercado
superior brasileiro
começamos um novo projeto que confesso
para vocês hoje é a menina dos meus
olhos e que me traz muito orgulho muito
entusiasmo
nós estamos começando mais campos mas
campos é uma rede de cooperação que nós
estamos criando instituições de ensino
que tenham a que tenham tradição
acadêmica e que sejam referência em
educação presencial mas que tem um pouco
ou nenhuma experiência em educação a
distância
então nós temos crianças a rede de
cooperação nós nós vamos prover a parte
toda de tecnologias e plataformas além
disso a forte captação e vendas e as
instituições de ensino e entram com suas
marcas com o seu corpo docente e com a
sua infraestrutura
me sinto neste momento um privilegiado
porque sempre de alguma maneira ou outra
nós militamos na educação mas o papel de
editor é muito difícil mensurar o
benefício que a gente pode causar nos
estudantes e agora com esse projeto nós
temos o privilégio de talvez mudar o
paradigma da educação superior no nosso
país porque a pretensão aqui é conseguir
oferecer uma educação de qualidade e com
baixo custo ou seja inclusivo aqui
mostra pra vocês um pouco a evolução
esse corte de 2015 quando como
conseguimos fazer a transição em 2015
foi o ano da virada em 2015 nós
conseguimos já que metade das receitas
da empresa viessem do negócio historial
e metade já como já vinham dos dos novos
negócios
qual é a única certeza que eu tenho hoje
a única certeza que eu tenho hoje é que
muitas incertezas irão e imensos
desafios vão se avizinha e que tomara
que a gente continue conseguindo
transformar as desafios e ameaças em
oportunidades e como é uma palestra
sobre conhecimento eu vou deixar algumas
lições tomara que seja útil algumas
lições que aprendi o resto da vida são
são lições simples e basicamente de
empreendedorismo e espero que possam ser
úteis
tá eu acho que essa pra mim principal a
questão de consistência e coerência
não existe milagre não existe uma uma
solução mágica com superpoderes ou super
heróis e eu acho que não existem e o que
existe é o trabalho aquele trabalho
diuturno acordar todo dia cedo e cada
dia se fazer a mesma coisa mas com um
pouquinho melhor a cada dia fazer no dia
anterior mas um pouquinho melhor e isso
vai criando é uma atração e um momento
que que acaba chegando
outra coisa que eu acredito muito na
sessão das estratégias emergentes
esse foi o termo cunhado por um autor
nós é um pensador canadense rmm inter
ele é um crítico do planejamento
estratégico e eu acho planejamento
estratégico é importante para conseguir
alinhar a equipe mas no longo prazo é
muito difícil que a gente consiga
eu previa todo tudo o que vai acontecer
com a empresa - com as nossas vidas
então o que eu acredito muito que cada
que a gente tem que atuar
tem que aprender com os erros e acho que
é melhor se arrepender do que se fez do
que se fez o que pôde fazer aqui no
nosso caso cada uma das iniciativas que
nós tivemos acabou acabaram dando
desdobramentos que era completamente
imprevisíveis momento da sua concepção e
acho que no fim e também acho que fica a
a a lição que principalmente no no mundo
atual que só os os paranóicos sobrevivem
há pelo menos na minha na minha
trajetória não tive nenhum momento de
que pude ficar tranqüilo e achar que a
missão estava cumprida eo problema
resolvido eu mostrei pra você está magra
o rio agora quando eu comecei a
trabalhar algo que eu nunca imaginava
atingir poderia ter sido o ápice da
minha trajetória no fim ele foi apenas
um ponto de inflexão então acho que
assim a insatisfação permanente algo que
o que acho que é importante que nos move
on acho que o segredo do sucesso é isso
é isso pessoal obrigado espero que seja
outra